[Alkış]
Evet Merhabalar Merhabalar
güzel olmak büyük keyif bugün Ne
anlatacağım size yeni nesil liderlik
yeni nesil liderliği kendi Hikayem
üzerinden anlatacağım Aslında ve neler
tecrübe ettik nasıl
düşüyoruz kalkıyoruz ve hayat nasıl bizi
eviriyor nasıl Aslında şekillendiriyor
buna bakıyor olacağız ben
ilk orta lise öğrenimi İzmit'te
tamamladım daha sonra üniversiteye
Eskişehir Anadolu şu anki adıyla
Osmangazi oldu beni Edebiyat Fakültesi
Matematik bölümünde bitirdim matematik
mezunuyum Yani Okul devam ederken
kendime a planı B planı Hani yapma
süreçleri o zaman da vardı stajlar yoktu
ama süreçte ve pedagojik formasyon
eğitimi aldım ve matematik öğretmenliğin
4.5 ay yaptım çok da güzel deneyimlerim
oldu Daha sonra okul bitti askerlik
güzel bir deneyim uzun dönem yapmıştım
ve daha sonra onun bana staj olduğunu
Aslında daha sonra öğrendim ve daha
sonra deneyimledim ve sonuçta
ilk bölüm tamam şimdi ne yapacağız işe
gireceğiz hayat kurmamız lazım ve hayata
akıtmamız lazım
Okul devam ederken deneyimler kazanırken
Sonuçta Hani süreçte yeni planlarda
yapmanız gerekiyor nerede yaşayacaksınız
hangi işi yapacaksanız bugün burada
gençler ile birlikteyiz dolayısıyla çok
genç arkadaşımla bir aradayız Hep aynı
soruyu soruyoruz geleceğin nasıl olacak
nasıl kuracaksın geleceğini Dolayısıyla
derken ben hayatın kırılma noktalarına
Çok inanırım arkadaşlar yani hayatta
hiçbir zaman düz çizgi değil hayatımız
düz şekilde gitmiyor belli dönemler Ee
siz de kendi hayatlarınıza bakın
iniyoruz ve belli noktalar bizim
hayatımızı çok etkiliyor Benim de
aslında belki birinci Kırılma Noktası
hayatımı İstanbul'da devam ettirme
kararı olması ve Ben geleceğimi
İstanbul'da kuracağım dedim Çünkü Ee o
süreçte Hani bir gelecek kurmaya
çalışıyorsunuz bir geleceği birlikte
Kurmaya çalıştığınız yol arkadaşınızla
bir karar alıyorsunuz babam bana şöyle
baktığını hatırlıyorum ya bu çocuk
akıllı ya da benziyordu akıllı birine de
benziyordu ama hani okulda bitirdi Şimdi
İstanbul nereden çıktı şimdi İzmit
Eskişehir ve hiç bilinmeyen bir şehir ve
İstanbul'da bir yolculuk ilk mücadele
Aslında böyle başladım dolayısıyla ne
ile başladı aileyi ikna etme ve oradaki
o rezilyanusu o dayanıklılığı test etme
süreci sonra ben tabii ki iş
başvurularına devam ediyorum birçok yere
başvuruyorum birçok şirket var işte
bankalar var firmalar var Dolayısıyla
görüşmelere gidiyorum geliyorum Sonra
bir görüşmedeyim ve başka bir ilan için
başvurdum Aslında
gittiğimde işte konuşuyoruz demiştim ya
hani askerlikteki beceriler aslında hani
farklı öğretiler kazandırmış farklı
farkında olmadan aslında bir şeyleri
doldurmuşuz ceplerimize bana şu soru
soruldu Cenk dedi sen insan kaynak
çalışmak ister misin Ben durdum İhsan
kartları ne yapar dedim bilmiyorum çünkü
Dolayısıyla 90'lı yıllar 96 Okulu
bitirdim 98 ve Hani o sürecin içinde
değişim değişim görüyorsunuz bakın hep
değişim Yani sürekli Hayat sizi bir
taraflara Aslında eviriyor ve Hani
süreçte karşınızda yeni fırsatlar
çıkartıyor dedim ki denerim işi
anlattılar Ondan sonra belki denerim
demeseydim şu anda karşınızda Hani bu 25
seneyi doldurmuş bir profesyonel olarak
konuşamayacaktım Sonuçta verdiğiniz
kararlar evet der hayırlar süreçte sizi
farklı bir tarafa veriyor ve yolunuzu
Aslında çeşitlendiriyor yolunuzu
şekillendiriyor sonra tabii ki yolculuk
başladı İstanbul hayatı başladı ve
İstanbul hayatında kendimizi aslında
yani bulmaya çalışıyoruz kendimizi ifade
kendi karakterimizle değerlerimiz de
kabul ettirmeye çalışıyoruz ve ben
çalışkan olmanın bir kişilik özelliği
olduğunu Çok inanırım sonradan kazanmak
çok kolay değil öğretilir Tabii ki hani
Çalışkan olmaya İnsan bir çaba gösterir
ama önemli olan içten gelmesidir onun
içten yanmalı olmak başka bir şeydir
Dolayısıyla bunu deneyimleyebiliyor
olmak önemli bir yandan kendi
değerlerimle gelişimi sağlamaya
çalışıyorum çözüm odaklı ve yaklaşmak
her zaman çok önemli Dolayısıyla Hani
Hayata hep öyle bakmışımdır ve Hani ana
liderliğin gelişimin burada olduğuna da
çok inanırım Dolayısıyla çözüm odaklı
olabilmek önemlidir kendi değerlerinizi
yansıtabilmek önemlidir bilgi çok
değerlidir Ama kendi karakterinizi de
orada saygıyı kazanıyorsunuz iş yerinde
iş hayatında işte dışındaki sosyal
hayatınızda o şekilde değerleri
yaşatıyorsunuz Dolayısıyla Hayat akıyor
bir yandan da düzenimizi kurmaya
Çalışıyoruz ve şimdi Hani Ee bir akış
halindeyiz ve yaşamı Aslında
anlamlandırmaya çalışıyoruz derken ilk
kırıldım demiştim ya İkinci kırılım
noktası
şirketimiz O anki firmamız bir anlamda
işini sonlandırma ve farklı bir sürece
girmemiz gerekti johnna'nın demiş ya
hayat sen plan yaparken başına gelenler
veya Yine Severim %10 başına gelense %90
verdiğin tepkiler Şimdi burada tekrar
karar verme anı ve o karar verme anında
Aslında süreçte karşınıza farklı
alternatifler çıkıyor Ben çok gençle bir
aradayım görevim gereği de bir de
gerçekten seviyorum da çünkü
besleniyoruz Karşılıklı birbirimizi
besliyoruz samimi şekilde fayda
sağlayabiliyor olmak hayatın anlamı ve o
doğrultuda hareket edebiliyor olmak da
çok değerli bizi değerli kılan da bu
aslında Dolayısıyla orada liderlerimi
benden deneyimli yöneticilerimi tekrar
istişare yaparak dinleme dönemi geldi ve
bu dinleme döneminde Tabii ki belli
kararlar alıyorsunuz ve tek başınıza
kararlarda size kalmıyor az önce içeride
yine kuliste konuşurken gençlerle sohbet
ediyorum ne olmak istiyorsunuz kuzuya
sorduğumda Gerçekten güzel cevaplar
geliyor arıyoruz diyorlar ve bu dönem Bu
nas bu yaz deneyeceğim diyorlar Çok
değerli Dolayısıyla Hani sizden daha
büyük liderleri dinliyor olmak ve ona
göre bir hayatınıza yön verebiliyor
olmak çok çok değerli bu süreçte Tabii
ki karşımıza alternatifler çıktı ve
farklı firmada farklı bir şu anki
olduğum kurumda bir yolculuk başladı ve
Hani başka bir bankaya Aslında geçiş
yapmış olduk burada ne ön plana çıktı
yine Kendinizi de birlikte o değerleri
yaşatabiliyor olmak Yani kendiniz olmak
adaletli olmak Güven duyulan olmak
dürüst olabiliyor olmak çözüm odaklı
olmak şeffaf olmak çok çok değerli bugün
günümüzde de ön plana çıkan Aslında
kişilik özellikleri ve liderliğin en
temel gelişiminin en temel unsurları
Dolayısıyla öyle olduğunuz zaman zaten
Ee çok daha yolculuk keyifli oluyor ve
hayatı akıtıyorsunuz şimdi
süreç devam ediyor Şans ve şanssızlık
kavramı çok karşımıza çıkar değil mi
yeni fırsatlar çıkar acaba çok mu
şanslısınız çok mu şanslısınız
Dolayısıyla mevcut kurumda yolculuk
devam ediyor bugüne kadar yaptığınız Ve
arkada bıraktığınız izler de değerli
olandır yani hayatınıza bir bakın
hayatta ne izler bıraktınız ve nasıl
aslında anılıyorsunuz sizinle ilgili
neler söylüyorlar Siz kendinizi nasıl
konumlandırıyorsunuz ben şöyle lafı çok
severim kendine iyi olmayan kimseyi iyi
olamaz yani kendine iyi gelmeyen kimseye
iyi gelemez Dolayısıyla Önce kendimize
iyi bakacağız kendimizi besleyeceğiz
etrafımıza paydaşlarımıza ve
bulunduğumuz Aslında sisteme fayda
sağlayabilelim Eğer amaç anlam buysa çok
daha iyi bir şekilde yolculuk devam
ediyor Eee şu tarafta baktığımızda Şans
ve şanssızlık kavramını Hani Ee dönecek
olursam hazırsınız diyelim ki Birol
çıktı ve edildi şansımız Tabii ki şansın
faydası var ama siz hazırlanmışsınız
kendinize yatırım yapmışsınız ve bu
yatırımı sonucunu aslında bir şekilde
almışsınız Tabii ki şansın faydası var
ama bir de şöyle düşünün bir rol var Ve
siz hiç akla gelmiyorsunuz Dolayısıyla
hiçbir liderlik özelliğinizle hiçbir
kişilik özelliğinizle yönetim şeklinizle
bir iz bırakmamışsınız çok da şanssızım
diyorsunuz Bence bir düşünün diyoruz biz
bu şekilde yanıt veren profesyonellere
Çünkü insan hayatta kendi şansını da
kendisi yaratıyor ve iyi mücadele
oradaki çaba bir şekilde sonuca dönüyor
üçüncü kırılım noktası Tam da böyle bir
zamanda oldu aslında ve ee çok hani
sayılı üst yönetim rolleri çok hani
kolay açılmaz biliyorsunuz Dolayısıyla
herro çok değerli ve öyle bir şans doğdu
ve akla gelen olmak tabii ki Ee
gururlandırıyor
dedi ki yönetim Tabii ki heyecanlıyım
süreçte dedik ki kendi değerlerini
kuruma empoze etmeni bekliyoruz ve
hayırlı olsun beraberiz Dolayısıyla yeni
bir sayfa açılmıştı üçüncü kırılım
noktası Aslında buydu ve bu noktadan
itibaren Aslında çok daha
sorumluluğun arttığı ve bugüne kadar
yapılan bütün
liderlik tarzı gelişim süreç hepsine
birlikte bakacağım ve yeniden heyecanla
yola devam edeceğim süreç başlamıştı
şimdi bu noktada ekip çok önemli her
dönem önemli zaten ama Ee Beraber yola
çıkacağınız Arkadaşlarınıza Ben iyi
İşlerin iyi ruhlarla yapılacağına Çok
inanırım Dolayısıyla ekip kadar
başarılıyız yani liderlik stiliniz
liderlik tarzınız her bir yöneticinin
lideri olması gerektiğine de gönülden
inanırım dolayısıyla böyle bir süreç
başladı ekiple beraber yol haritası
belirlediğimizde ne istediğimi ne
istediğimizi ve kuruma nasıl değer
yapacağımız şekillendirdiğimizde öne
çıkan değerler şunlar oldu Evet biz
zaten başarılı bir insan kaynakları
ailesiydik Ama neye ihtiyacımız vardı
Neyi daha iyi yapmamız gerekiyordu Çok
kaliteli bir ekibimiz vardı zaten daha
da iyi noktaya getirmek ama temas etme
Dokunma Biraz sonra geleceğim hizmetkar
liderlik dediğimiz kavrama değer bilen
liderlik dediğimiz kavramı kuruma empoze
etme çok daha İhtiyaç olan bir durumdu
şubeler Genel Müdürlük bölgeler saha
ekipleri aradaki iletişim ve temas
noktaları bunları samimi şekilde bağ
kurabiliyor olmak ağır değil daha kurmak
hayattaki en temel noktalardan bir
tanesi bu dolayısıyla her yaptığınız
süreçte her yaptığınız kurguda bu akışı
yürütebiliyor olmak çok çok değerli
dolayısıyla böyle bir yolculuğa başladık
Ve gerçekten heyecan kattık koruma Ee
çok dinamizm getirdik şu anda hani
süreçte
10 Hani büyük bir yapıyı yönetiyoruz ve
büyük bir yapının içinde Aslında
dokunarak temas ederek dokunan değer
katan Lider ika tanımını kurum bize
verdi ve Bu doğrultuda yönetimle
birlikte bütün paydaşlarımızla birlikte
süreci devam ettiriyoruz asıl buradaki
kılavuzumuz demiştim ya hizmetkar
Liderlik nedir bu hizmetkarlığı bir kere
dinlemek anlamak için dinlemek Biz
anlamak için dinliyoruz ve yeni nesil
liderliğin en temel noktalarından bir
tanesi bu Dolayısıyla dinlemek gerekiyor
çözüm için dinlemek gerekiyor karşı
tarafa değer verdiğini hissettirmen
gerekiyor samimi olmak gerekiyor
Dolayısıyla içinde tabii ki takım olma
var birlikte olma hali var Dolayısıyla
iyileştirme hali var her zaman başarılı
olamazsınız hayatta hani başarılı
başarısızlık buradaki süreçte ne var
başarısızlığı olduğunuzda da başarıya
nasıl gidecek süreç bunu
değerlendirebiliyor bunu
cesaretlendirebiliyor olma var
ekibiyle birlikte
ekibiyle birlikte Aslında gelişime
hizmet etme var gelişime liderlik etme
var Bu doğrultuda devam ediyor süreç ve
biz Hani 2019'da özellikle 2018'in
ortasında başlayan 2019'da devam eden
süreçte bu noktayı kaçırmadan yola devam
ettik Hayat dedim ya kırılma noktaları
Biraz da şans mıdır şanssızlık mıdır
bizi mi buluyor dedik kendi aramızda da
çok hani bunun konuşmasını yapıyoruz
dördüncü Kırılma Noktası hepimizi çok
ciddi etkileyen pandemi 2020'nin Mart
ayında hepimizi bir anlamda evlere
kapatan ne yapacağımızı ilk başta
bilemediğimiz ve ilk padikane
Dolayısıyla Biz çok süreci test ederiz
yenilikçi ve gelişimi açık olmak çok
önemli buradaki süreçte daha önce test
ettiğimiz çeşitli çalışma modellerini
çok kısa sürede Tabii ki deneyimleme
şansı oldu ve ne yaptık o hani
asker liderlik anlayışı değer bilen
liderlik anlayışı önce insan sonra
dediğimiz önce insan sonra çalışan
dediğimiz süreç bir anda daha derin
şekilde kurum tarafından hissedildi
çalışanlarımız tarafından hissedildi
Burada da samimiyet var başta öyle
değilseniz sonra böyle olmanız mümkün
değil arkadaşlar Dolayısıyla buradaki
süreç kendi için de doğal olarak
sahiplenildi önce sağlık anlayışıyla
oradaki süreçte şefkati değer bilen
liderliği vicdanlı yönetimi çok daha
çalışanlarımız hissetti
müşterilerimiz aileleri aynı şekilde
Geçen gün Google'da Ee Google'ın arama
kelime şeyle butonuna bastığınızda
Şefkat Vicdan ne kadar çok arandığını
Sizler de görebilirsiniz Dolayısıyla
yeni dönem trendlerde Aslında bu çok
daha ön planda ve bu süreç buradaki
süreçte dönüşümü görüyorsunuz Bu süreçte
pandemiye kadar Aslında üç kırılım
değişiyoruz sonra tekrar geçmişe
dönüyoruz Aynı hataları belki Tekrar
yapıyoruz Hani tekrar bakıyoruz ama
gündemi bir dönüşüm süreci Hiçbirimiz
aynı insan değiliz artık yani geçmişe
dönmeyi barındırmıyor birçok özelliğimiz
değişti ve çok büyük bir değişim
sürecine girdik buradaki o el Hani
Omuzdaki el veya sarıp sarmalama hali
şefkat yeni dönem yeni nesil liderlik
olarak Bundan sonraki süreçte çok daha
gerekli teknoloji gelişim inovasyon
olmazsa olmaz Ama bunu insanla
birleştirebiliyor olmak o hizmetkarl
liderliği yaşatarak devam edebiliyor
olmak en değerlisi ve bundan sonra da en
gerekli olalım neler değişti liderlik
anlayışı Değiştir dedim ya gerçekten
şimdi bütün şirketler bütün kurumlar
birey olarak herkes Aslında Bu
doğrultuda gitmeye çalışıyor ama kim
bunu Sürdürülebilir kılacak samimi
yapanlar samimi yapanlar güzel bir
aileyiz derken ailesindeki birey gibi
gerçekten oradaki hizmet ettiği
insanlara çalışanı olabilir müşterisi
olabilir Hiç fark etmez paydaşları
olabilir yani o kendi sosyal hayatındaki
gruplar olabilir buradaki süreçte o
şefkati o değer bilen liderliği ve o
vicdanlı yönetimi ön planda tutması
gerekiyor herkesin deneyimleme alanı
değişti deneyimleme öncelikleri değişti
deneyimleme yeri değişti Yani pandemide
eminim buradaki grupta ne kadar zorlandı
hepimizde benzer Hikayeler var
Dolayısıyla Bunların hepsinden düşmek
kalkmak yani 7 kere düşüyorsak 8 kere
kalkabiliyor olmak çok değerli oldu ben
bu süreçte 4 tane ana yeteneği hep ön
planda tuttum ve herkese de söyledim
bunu ne bunlar bir kere Umut da olmak
pozitif bakmak yani hayatta pozitif
bakabiliyor olmak çok değerli umutla
bakabiliyor olmak her zaman da umutlu
olmak hayali olanın bir hayatı oluyor
yani hayaliniz varsa o hayal peşinde
koşuyorsunuz ve hayatınızı
şekillendirmeye çalışıyorsunuz hiç
değişmeyen bir kural bu ne de olursa
olsun Hayal kurabiliyor olmak değerli
içten yanmalı olmak çok çok değerli
Çünkü Bu dönemlerde zor dönemlerde
birçok süreci test etmek zorunda kaldık
ve o anda kendimize özümüze ihtiyacımız
vardı kendimizi İyi Etmeye kendimiz o
enerjiyle ayağa kalkmaya ihtiyacımız
vardı bu çok değerli bir de dedim ya
düşüyorsan kalk Yedi kere düşüyorsan 8
kere kalk 8 kere düşüyorsa 9 kere kalk
her seferinde Ayağa kalkma heyecanını
bulabiliyor olmak oldukça kritik 2020
zor başladı hep beraber ülke olarak
kenetlendiğimiz bir süreç yaşadık Hayat
hep sürprizler çıkartabiliyor karşımıza
dedim ya biz plan yaparken başınıza
gelenler mutlu olmak hayatın amacı mıdır
bir sorarım size Dolayısıyla içinde
mutluluklarımız var mutsuzluklarımız var
bunlarla ilgili çok değerli yayınlar da
var ama gerçekten şu çok önemli bir
hayatınızın anlamı ne neden bu
hayattasınız ve o anlama dair amacınız
Dolayısıyla Neyi hedefliyorsunuz Bu
doğrultuda yaşayabiliyor olmak çok çok
değerli kararlı şekilde gittiğinizde
başarılı olamayacak süreçte yok
dolayısıyla böyle bir süreçte bu değişen
dönüşen sürecin içinde dinamizmin içinde
Aslında
liderlik anlayışı olarak hizmetkar
liderliği benimseyen ve uygulayan kişi
kurum olarak günümüzün bizi çok daha iyi
noktaya götüreceğine gönülden inanıyorum
geleceği değer bilen hizmet eden ve
etkili liderlerin şekillendireceğine de
gönülden inanıyorum ben liderliğin
yetkisiz etki kadar olduğunu ele
yanıyorum liderin apoletleri yok
Dolayısıyla Siz Aslında süreci nasıl
yönetiyorsunuz ve oradaki süreçte
apoletler olmadan ne kadar etki
yaratabiliyorsunuz bu çok değerli ve
yolculuk da aslında o zaman daha anlamlı
geçen gün bir yöneticimiz şunu dedi Ee
bu çıktığımız yolculuğu şöyle kırılım
noktalarıyla size anlattığımda buradaki
yeni nesil liderlik tarzına
güzel yıllarınız olsun diyorum bu yıl Ee
Cumhuriyetimizin 100 yılını kutluyoruz
biliyorsunuz Benim de 50 yaşım olacak 73
doğumluyum Ben aynı anda Eee ve hani
böyle bir heyecanı yaşıyor olmak çok çok
değerli güzel bir geleceğimiz olsun
Cumhuriyet dolu yarınlarımız olsun
teşekkür ediyorum dinlediğiniz için
[Alkış]